Eight years ago, President Barack Obama looked
fresh-faced and young, now he looks like someone's
pop-pop.
Does holding the highest office in the land
age people faster?
Hey village elders, Trace here for DNews.
The President of the United States of America
is likely one of the most stressful jobs around,
on-call 24 hours a day, constantly visible
by the world's media, citizens, and of course,
enemies.
Being the Leader of the Free World is bound
to take it's toll after four or eight years.
Commonly, people cite pictures of presidents
and how greyer, or aged they end up looking.
Obama quipped to the fresh faced Canadian
PM Justin Trudeau, "if you don’t want to
go grey like me, you need to start dying [your
hair] soon before it’s too late!"
But DO presidents age faster?
Today, the president never goes anywhere without
the Physician to the President, and meticulous
records of the president's health care, of
course, kept.
So, Dr. Michael Roizen (chief wellness officer
at the Cleveland Clinic) looked at records
from every president from Teddy Roosevelt
to George W. Bush to find a pattern, and he
thinks, "presidents age twice as fast."
Roizen looked at the Commanders in Chief's
diet, blood pressure, physical activity, and
lifestyle finding the level chronic stress
was high, and the ability to blow off steam
with friends and family (which would lessen
stress) was low.
Stress has huge effects on the human body!
Things like immune system response, cardiovascular
function, motivation and mood, not to mention
how your body processes food and how much
fat you store are all worsened by stress,
and… it also affects aging.
A study in Nature Genetics found chronic exposure
to stress will shorten telomeres.
Telomeres are a chunk of DNA on the end of
each of our chromosomes, think... the things
on the tips of your shoelaces (called aglets,
btw).
As they replicate, the telomeres shrink, and
the DNA eventually becomes more easily damaged!
Scientists think this is what causes aging.
And according to many studies, stress increases
the telomere shortening process!
And thus, increases the speed of aging!
The thing is, Roizen is just one opinion.
Another doctor, Jay Olshansky of the University
of Illinois-Chicago, disagrees with him.
Olshansky believed wealth, education and healthcare-access
all increase presidential lifespan.
And modern-day presidents definitely have
those.
Is incredible how much wealth, education and
healthcare access helps people live longer,
healthier lives, amirite?
But, what if they're both right?
What if because of chronic stress while in
the White House, presidents age faster, but
then because of their access to wealth and
health care -- they live "better" lives after
their terms end?
This may be true… but, according to a study
in the British Medical Journal they die sooner.
Researchers tracked how many years they lived
AFTER a candidate's last election.
279 national leaders in 17 countries from
1722 until 2015 were studied and researchers
found: elected leaders lived 4.4 fewer years
than their unelected brethren.
Yikes.
One thing is without a doubt, over the last
eight years, Barack Obama is getting greyer
up top.
In fact, a study in Proceedings of the Natural
Institute of Science compared his hair over
time.
They found, he was, in fact, getting greyer
at point-452 percent more per year (when compared
to actor Morgan Freeman).
Science is so awesome.
Look, there have only been 44 presidents so
far, and only a handful alive at any given
time.
To study them as a group is reallllly difficult,
and it might just all be in our heads.
According to Dr. Olshansky, Obama is not necessarily
aging faster, we just notice because he's
ALWAYS out there.
We are watching him change, so when we see
an old picture it is just… a shock.
See?
Crazy, right?